as we get into our superlatives coming
out of week six
i i feel like one of the awards should
be called cream of the crop rises to the
top i think that should be a weekly
award do you have one that would fit
into that
into that label oh uh no i don't
come back to me and i'll think about
that a little bit all right
um i'm not ready for that yet yeah you
know what i don't either because most of
mine are focused on
on uh on negatives although let me start
with the bears
yeah um it's been an hour since we've
spoken about the chicago bears
and i don't know maybe maybe we should
give them cream of the crop rise it's at
the top they're five and one
yeah right i i you know and and it's
just this
they're just kind of there and we expect
them to lose
and they don't and yeah and it's
it's i don't get it i don't know i mean
that's it's what happens when you have a
great defense yeah but we still look at
them and we're like
oh they are it's not there's no style
points with the bears there's no and
at least like to me they're finally
embracing what they are
that's where i kind of like what i'm
seeing by the bears i think they finally
realized like what
listen we're never gonna have a great
offense let's just be somewhat good
not turn the ball over our defense is
really good i mean it's dominant like
you said
they've been a little fortunate with
their schedule as we've seen
but you know they answered those
questions with a win against the bucks
where i think that silences that and
carolina and the way that looks so
the bears are going to be in this as
long as they aren't stupid on the
offensive side of the ball
you could see their defense is going to
keep them in a game versus any team in
football
because they really got it all i should
have made the bears the best bet last
week because when i saw they were
underdogs it's like
this is this is it this is the formula
this is the recipe they're going to be
upset
and and there's an energy to this team
that is unexpected here's nick foles
after the game and i don't think we've
ever seen nick foles like this even
after he won super bowl 52 have a listen
well i first say would you rather uh
lose pretty
or win ugly i think that we'd rather win
ugly
um you know i think that's the common
thing so
i think it tells you a lot about our
team is this who we are often say we
want to improve we want to get better we
want to have rhythm but ultimately in
the nfl it's about winning games
um it doesn't matter how you do it just
matters that you get it done
if you put up 50 points and you lose a
game those 50 points don't mean anything
um so right now we're winning games
we're playing together as a team
we can improve i think that's exciting
if we were winning these games and
playing perfect and they were this tight
and we're playing perfect
what do you do where do you improve i
mean then we're sitting here it's like
man i
i guess when we just you know play those
teams it's just not going to happen well
right now
we have a lot of areas to improve
offensively once again
but we are figuring out ways to you know
score and get points and move the ball
and do those things
we can fix what we're doing it doesn't
happen overnight offenses don't get
fixed overnight sometimes they don't get
fixed throughout the course of years
you've seen an nfl there's been teams
that have been bad
offensively for a very long time we're
not one of those teams we're a team
that's young
offensive we're growing we're getting to
know each other we're figuring out who
we are
and we're doing it at the right time and
as a team we're winning these games
and i think that's what's important now
we're not going to get complacent and
say hey man we're five and one this is
it no
like we're sitting there in the locker
room after the game talking through it
hey we gotta be better here this is what
we gotta do here communication here
route running here
hey we gotta be able to run the ball
here we know that i know you are gonna
ask those questions we know that
and that's what's exciting because we
don't have to have y'all say hey you're
doing this hey we know
but we also know that we're going to
improve because we believe in one
another
and that's what great teams do great
teams find a way to win a game
bad teams win with prettiness great
teams
win no matter how it takes so i'm proud
of our guys
i i i think we're continuing to improve
are we where we want to be no we're not
where we want to be but i'm excited
about our offense i'm
excited about the guys that are there
i'd like the communication that's
happening on silent i love the passion
of the players
most important they care and we're
bonding we're getting to know each other
that's football like you don't just go
out there and play football
you got to care about the man next to
you to make those plays
so i like where we're at i know we're
going to improve
i believe in our staff i believe in our
players and i'm really grateful to be a
part of this organization
probably one of the longest quotes we've
ever played during the show but
that's it like what happened to nick
falls who's that guy
that guy is engaged he's locked in he's
excited
about this team uh unlike most people i
mean
there's a nastiness there's an edge not
in a mean way but there's just something
there you know the
chip on the shoulder that's never going
to go away and they're going to need it
chris
next week monday night football at the
rams the following week
the saints the following week at the
titans then they get a bye week
against the vikings then they get their
real bye week and then they have to go
to green bay for sunday night football
so
uh they've got some tests coming up that
could eat into that five on one schedule
but like i said last night
if you're five and one um you go five
and five the rest of the way you're ten
and six you're in the playoffs that's
right they just have to they just have
to go 500 the rest of the way and
they're in
and i think you know i i think first off
nick foles what he just said there
that that was awesome i mean it really
was i think he's basically
he's going i've had enough i got to take
leadership of this offense and be a
voice for the team here a little bit
because he's probably hearing some of
the same things
that everybody's talking about oh it's
ugly what's going on
you know hey this is the way they are as
a football team and he's right they're
still growing and
and coming together as far as what they
want to do on the offensive side of the
ball there is there's obviously area to
improve there
and that's encouraging when you're five
and one you go man we haven't really
played a complete football game yet and
here we are you know but i do think that
he
just within that answer he
that that that to me is like why you
make the switch it just
he understands the full scope of the
team and the organization
and where they're at and he gets where
the offense is at and he understands
that defense is amazing
and i think he's just going to go okay
if i got to be a game manager
per se and just you know be a little
more conservative and protect the
football
and just make a play here or there to
win a football game
he's got no problem with that you know
just like we saw last thursday night
against the bucks game too
that was ugly but like in the two or
three biggest drives of the game
he kind of willed the team down there as
ugly as it might have been oh slam that
one in there get it in there
he did the same thing yesterday you know
some ugly field goal drives but they
kind of keep it going and that's where
he's special and unflappable that way uh
as far as a quarterback is concerned
the thing that cracks me up about him
like he slips into that mode where
everything's working and there's an
urgency like to to get as many yards and
points as possible
before it it's like a jekyll and hyde
thing like he goes back to being a guy
who
isn't as effective but he's still good
enough right but those moments where he
slides into the zone feel temporary but
you know you you get enough points out
of it you end up winning games
and uh even though the one loss the
bears have happened when he was the
starter
they've done very well since then and uh
they're on their way
it's just it's going to be a real test
coming up starting next monday night
against the la rams all right chris what
do you have
uh i mean i think i got to give the uh i
forgot we were in superlatives there we
talked about the bears so much
the uh the shh award
and i'm gonna give that to philip rivers
for his performance yesterday because
that game of course started out shaky
and the bengals got out to a really good
lead i mean that
that colts defense that i i was so
impressed by
man the cleveland browns tear them up
and then joe burrow comes out yesterday
and making plays all over the field just
moving the ball up and down you're going
whoa
what's going on colts couldn't really
find their rhythm
but rivers just as the game went on
just slowly wore them down and made a
lot of big time throws i mean his
ability to throw like
15 and 20 yard crossers and drop them
into these little windows and things
like that
really really impressive that way and
they did not panic being down what was
it at one point 21-0
uh you know that's that's why you got
phillip rivers right there
for that type of game asleep at the
wheel against the bangles we should beat
them
oh crap things aren't going well we need
a quarterback
that can kind of execute a hurry up
offense and start making the plays
phillip rivers came through uh in the
clutch in a big way for them yesterday
you know they never should have been
behind the way they were it never should
have been as close as it was but i guess
that's the mark of a good team where
they don't just fold the tents they
don't just give up they don't just
surrender and say we'll get them next
week they find a way to take a day that
isn't there since we were talking about
earlier with
browns and otto beckham jr you find a
way
to make the days that don't feel like
they're going your way into a day that
does go your way and ultimately they get
the win
and we feel very differently about the
cults today than we would have if they
hadn't pulled that one off all right the
next one for me
scholarship year award scholarship year
back in effect for a team that
falls behind and just doesn't seem to
care that they've fallen behind because
everybody's got job security
this year doesn't count it's pandemic we
don't have fans line up the excuses
it's the minnesota vikings kirk cousins
they're stuck with him through 2022.
and uh right out of the gates i knew it
the first throw the game intercepted
that's it falcons are going to win
boom i that that's it i knew it at that
moment
and to their credit to their credit the
falcons did not
uh do what they normally do we'll talk
more about that coming up but the
vikings
cousins gets the new contract dalvin
cook
gets the new contract mike zimmer gets
the new contract
rick spielman gets the new contract
nobody's getting fired after this year
they can be as bad as they want to be
this year nobody's getting fired next
year well
you know maybe they'll be on the hot
seat but next year's next year we got to
get we're going to get through 2020
before we worry about 2021.
and i just think that all of the various
factors have come together
when you throw in the pandemic chris
where i just
i feel like the the vikings lack that
desire to go out there and win
consistently
collect there's just there's there's
something's missing there and i think
when you have that many key members of
the team
that are on scholarship this year that's
that's what you get and maybe next year
they'll be better but
that doesn't matter when you're trying
to get through this year no well it
definitely doesn't i mean
you know you turn over the ball like
that early on the football game it just
it's so hard to overcome it
i don't care who you're playing and the
falcons still have offensive weapons
but i hear what you're saying hey my big
thing was the minnesota
vikings what's disappointing where i
just look at it and go is that
they let the seattle seahawks beat them
twice you know that's just the way the
game looked to me
it was one of the things i said early on
in the meeting room yesterday when all
of us were watching the game i just
went oh they got hangover from the game
last week where
man they knew they blew it they should
have won the game against the seahawks
had the fourth and one
big hole whatever blew all these
opportunities
to where it just looked like it affected
their psyche or the way they played
you know against the atlanta falcons who
you know played motivated football yeah
you know raheem morris he's he's great
friends with mike tomlin
and because he's got this great
personality and you could see at least
atlanta played with energy
and there was some some fire and they
were flying around that way yesterday so
good for them certainly but
yeah that's just like let me ask you a
question yeah yeah
because i heard you say it yesterday and
i agree with you they let what happened
in seattle
affect and infect the team this week
whose job is it to keep that from
happening
i'm curious i'm not being sarcastic
whose job is it to keep that from
happening yeah i mean
that would be to me the head coach i
mean that was where that would
start that would be one of those things
where you know that's such a
big loss it's such a downer you got to
realize that your team
probably is going to sulk a little bit
for 24 hours and your coach
you got to almost make a point like
wednesday morning this is like just my
experience
you know a few times where you lose a
game like that that's heartbreaking
the coaches got to come in there and pep
everybody up
and really keep them on you know on task
and and have a message for the week to
kind of
get that in the rear view mirror that
bad taste out of our mouth
you know i don't know what happened
there but that's usually how you know i
saw it play out in my my career
i just sense with a handful of teams
this year
kind of an ah bleep it
attitude like you know this year's had
all this stuff just pile up and at a
certain point
you just don't care anymore and i've
that's been the vibe
from the moment they got on the field
against the packers
that's been the vibe and yes they beat
the texans and yes they gave the titans
everything they could handle and yes
they gave the seahawks everything they
could handle but you lose those games
against great teams
and it really does feed this idea that
eh not this year here's kirk cousins
from after the game talking about
his interceptions and what the eventual
consequences could be
you just have to play well you know in
this business and the reality is
if if the pace you know that i'm on in
terms of
the interceptions if that were to
continue uh
you know i i won't finish the season
um sean mannion's the backup kurt you
will finn
i said kurt accidentally i usually i do
it on purpose at kirk
sean mann is the backup you are
finishing the season no matter how many
interceptions you throw and
your salary for next year is 21 million
fully guaranteed oh and
on uh uh the third day of the 2021
league year his full 35 million dollar
salary for 2022 becomes fully guaranteed
the vikings couldn't just let him enter
the last year of his contract and taking
their chances on the other side
chris they didn't and they made a huge
financial mistake and they have tied
their hands
and what are they gonna what kind of
brock osweiler hot potato trade are they
gonna have to do
to get out from under this contract and
they won't they won't they'll say
all the things i'm saying now just with
kind of you know different words and
different attitude but like this is a
lost season
it just happens but there's no cause to
to throw the baby out with the bathwater
start throwing in all the cliches
they're going to bring everybody
back they're going to learn from this
year and they're going to be better next
year and yada yada yada
they'll make it to the playoffs and
they'll lose in the opening round and
then they'll miss the playoffs the next
year and it's this cycle that's going to
continue forever
which is one of the reasons why i've
indulged my relationship with the team
after 50 years yeah
okay it sounds like you're still
emotionally invested to me i don't know
just as a friend letting you know i'm
working my way through it
i'm working my way through it good i
want i hear you mike i'm not happy about
it i'm not happy it's come to this
i know that's my point yes i know you're
you're you're you're
yes you're frustrated i get it and i
understand your questions about kirk
cousins hey this is the one thing that i
ponder or don't understand sometimes you
know
kirk cousins is not the issue there in
minnesota
he makes a lot of great plays i just
think
you know they got kirk cousins and
they're not really
maximizing what you would do with kirk
cousins they're playing a style of
football where
yeah we want to run the football and
bootlegs and play actions and
that time kind of lends itself to a
quarterback who's
you know athletic and make plays off
schedule and do things like that
oh hey my offense because we're about
running the ball in bootlegs it's kind
of simple
but my quarterback will make a few plays
when nothing's there you know you talk
about it all the time right those are
the special quarterbacks that's not kirk
cousins game
kirk cousins is most special when he
has weapons and a real a system that
maximizes
his ability to read and recognize and
process information that's why mcveigh
and shanahan loved him
because yeah you might not be like
patrick mahomes the most talented guy in
the world
but i can tell you all these damn clues
about the 75 plays we're about to run
and you remember them all and you
dissect it all and everything like that
and minnesota's just not like that
they're they're very elementary in the
past game
so they don't really maximize what you
really want
from a guy like kirk cousins that way to
me that's where there's a little bit of
a
i don't know they're off as far as the
player and how they want to play
football
that doesn't exactly mesh the right way
to me on the outside looking in
yeah i agree with everything you're
saying and i i just they
the problem is handing out all those
contracts has tied their hands
and i can tell you i could write the the
text
of the mark ziggy wilf press conference
after the season as to what's going to
happen with the vikings it's all going
to be forgiven it's all going to be
forgotten and they're going to try it
again next year what else do you have
well
bad bird the bad bird awards you know
the baddest bird around is the ravens
they beat the eagles yesterday
car car right i mean the ravens beat the
eagles oh
i mean a raven couldn't really beat an
eagle in a fight though i mean we know
that right you know that right
i i don't know i i'm not i'm not up on
my ornithology
matt casey says no way and i agree i
mean there's no way a raven's gonna beat
an eagle just answer the question what
kind of eagle there's different
they all are bigger than ravens i think
so they're gonna win
all i know all i know is the edgar allan
poe poem
the menacing horror poem is the raven
not the eagle
so well you know there's something about
the rave and i'm not turning my back on
the raven no you're right that's why
that's the biggest baddest bird you're
right there's no doubt about it they
proved that they were the mean angry one
yesterday i mean kind of a weird game in
that baltimore ravens game
we saw you know lamar get off in the run
game and we thought
ooh they're going to blow them away and
they got the eagles in a bad spot
i'm still shocked they sat there and
left the eagles back in the football
game with that defense
you know just to me some peculiar throw
plays and defensive calls by the ravens
just
continuing to blitz and just leave their
guys with no help in the secondary
that let the eagles kind of you know
hang around
and carson once made a lot of big plays
but you know the ravens
yes good foot like ravens we know are
one of the best teams
do you feel like i do though i'm just
not i'm not blown away by the ravens
right now i'm not blown away by them i
mean they're still
really really damn good but i think
maybe there's a few teams in the afc
that i might rank ahead of them right
now as we sit here
who uh i feel like just the way it's
looked the last few weeks i'm
i'm gonna go tennessee in kansas city
above them
and i'm i'm probably gonna go pittsburgh
from what i've seen the last two weeks
with them too where i'd
probably give them the edge over
baltimore right now it's a slight edge
but yeah i just think baltimore letting
up big plays that way
offense is kind of hit or miss the last
few weeks i
i just i don't know they just don't seem
as dominant as last year to me
and letting that game get a hell of a
lot closer than it should have been you
know i finally got on board with you
picking the ravens to cover
and uh i i look up and hey 30 22 hey
they're fine they're still covered by a
half point and the next thing you know
is 30-28 and they almost found
themselves in overtime
they get a week off and then they get
the steelers uh so we're going to find
out and then they go to the colts and
then they go to the patriots and then
they have the titans
and then they play the steelers wow yes
we're going to learn a lot and then they
have the cowboys on uh on a thursday
night and then they're at the browns
so uh they got some tough games coming
up schedule gets very soft after that
they finish with jaguars giants and
bengals but uh the next several games
are gonna be big tests for the baltimore
ravens almost like what the 49ers are
having to deal with they really are all
right next
next one for me is the he is who we
thought he was award and that goes to
greg williams the defense coordinator of
the new york jets because
the comments he made last week about the
jets
defense isn't the only reason why they
give up so many points it was a shot at
the offense
and uh adam gase the coach of the team
said yesterday after the game he wasn't
happy that greg williams
did that well when you hire greg
williams what the hell
do you expect this guy must be the
greatest defensive mastermind
in nfl history notwithstanding his
performance this year because he keeps
getting jobs
he is who he is he's been who he is an
objectionable person
a guy who was was running bounties in
every locker room that he was in
the nfl didn't go down that rabbit hole
but you had people coming he got sued
by somebody who got injured when he was
running a bounty in washington
allegedly i don't know that we need to
say allegedly we know it he got busted
for it he got suspended for a year
he submitted an affidavit uh ratting out
jonathan vilma
uh as part of the the i mean it's just
amazing that the guy still keeps finding
jobs
and when you hire him you you you know
what you're getting yourself into
you know what you're getting yourself
into so i i can't really
feel bad for adam gase because he hired
the guy
yeah but he didn't we hear a lot of
conversation
that there was a okay i mean you know
better than me i'm just saying that was
that talk right
he was forced on him a little i just i
just remember that i don't know that
either though
but but regardless look well then the
jets got who they
whoever it was that made the decision to
hire greg williams
got who they they uh they should have
expected to get
and it was not good yesterday for the
jets and one of the reasons if you've
got this friction
with greg williams and adam gase yeah
is that going to make it any easier to
go down to miami oh be competitive no
i thought they had a chance i thought
they'd be i thought they'd cover they
didn't score a point
the point the point differential you see
them the man
look at that that's the try that's the
george costanza trifecta
the bag over the face the mask over the
bag
and drinking the beer got a mask under
that bag too i see it there that's
good and the mask the mask is yes so
it's the what is it when it's four is it
a quinella i don't know i don't know the
horse racing terms is it cornella
cornella means something i don't know
but anyway uh the jets are horrible the
jets the jets are horrible yeah and i
feel bad for adam gase
i feel like he is caught in a vortex
that he just can't get out of and at
this point i would want to be fired
i would want it to end they've given up
what
their point differential is minus 110
they're on pace to have the worst point
differential in league history
they're on pace to be one of the worst
teams in league history
and this is one of those where i don't
know how you get off the ride you just
shall stop the ride i want to get off
but if i was a jets fan i'd want to get
off the ride if i was
adam gase i'd want to get off the ride
if i'm greg williams
i'd want to get off the ride maybe the
best way gays could get back at williams
is just just walk away provoke his
firing so he gets his
severance and let williams take over
this mess for the rest of the year good
luck greg
have fun yeah it's just i it's it it
really
is we know they're rebuilding and it's
going to take some time you can't be
this bad
and expect to not have everyone get
fired
no you're right i mean you're hoping for
like a dolphins like rebound like we saw
last year at the end of the year but i
just i think there's there's less
there's way less
of a chance of that happening you know
the dolphins still had playmakers still
one of the best corners in football and
xavier and howard
and you know uh parker you know devonte
parker was one of the best receivers in
football last year
i mean there was to latch on to let
alone like the dolphins where
last year i think we were also sitting
there going i don't know if they'll win
a game this year
at least there was something about the
future they were trading away assets and
doing things to where you were going
man they got a lot of great picks coming
their way though so they might be able
to do this
the jets there's like zero silver lining
zero i don't know what to look at you
don't know what to point to
you know i like the what they did in the
draft
you know but other than that there's
just nothing to latch on to
as far as oh this is a bright spot of
the team or this player oh he has a
chance to be a superstar
there's none of that across the board
and
then here they are with the quarterback
and sam darnold where
yeah what is this year three for him and
we're talking if they go
in 16 they're going to draft trevor
lawrence which they probably should four
sorry you're here four
year four no it's your three eighteen
nineteen twelve yeah get my math wrong
it is your four 18 19 it's three it's
four
ta ti see tom this is what you do i'm
sorry i miscounted
it's three it's three you're wrong yeah
it's three yeah right three yeah
i'm saying i acknowledge it i
acknowledge it i was wrong but that just
tells you where they're at
that's where they're at when you when
you you have a top three quarterback
draft pick and then
here we are gonna be four years later
they're going to talk about taking
the number one pick trevor lawrence for
clemson if he comes out if he's crazy
enough to want to come out and be
dropped by the jets
how about this next week buffalo bills
week eight at kansas city chiefs week
nine
monday night football chris berman
better go back to canada and get more
dues for this one jets at patriots
monday or patriots at jets not that it
matters uh seeing ghosts part two
and then the bye week i i would be
stunned
first of all if they win any of those
games and i will be beyond stunned if
adam gase has his job the day after
if he makes it that long if he makes it
out of today because who the hell knows
right we didn't know what was coming
with bill o'brien we kind of thought
maybe it was coming with dan quinn we
had no idea what was coming with thomas
dimitrov you never know until it happens
but if if if he loses these next three
games how is he chris howe
and i would want to be please put me out
of my misery please
well it seems inevitable like i mean
it's gonna happen and you're right i
just uh
where where are we going at what point
do they just want to go all right
it's over let's kind of start our you
know de facto
coach search right now and get out in
front of it
um and i think that time is probably
coming here in new york uh
you know sooner rather than later um
and and here's the thing here's the
thing who are you gonna who are you
gonna attract to come coach that mess
uh unless you have trevor lawrence
that's the only way
so all right you got one more uh well i
mean i might if we're gonna talk about
one
crappy team in new york and give them
love let's talk about the other crappy
team that actually won the game
all right big blue wrecking crew
yeah i'm giving the big blue wrecking
crew to the the giants because of that
defensive touchdown
they had uh ugly game one of the ugliest
games to watch yesterday
all together daniel jones made a few
good plays with its legs did stuff like
that
big touchdown pass to darius sladen but
the game was deadlocked 13
all as you know and there's the
washington team
driving down getting close to field goal
territory
they get the big strict the strip sack
fumble kyle uh kyle thackerell
gets it and then take crowder picks it
up you know for a game that there wasn't
a lot to talk about or anything like
that
that was a big play and a big moment
good to see joe judge
get off the schneid get his first career
win all of those things
happy for uh my new york football giants
yeah but you know what it means you know
what it means chris yeah it means the
the washington football team is going to
have a higher spot in the draft order
now it's the chase young ball all over
again
they're going to get some other guy
that's going to help them get better
because they lost a game to the giants
that nobody's going to remember a year
from now well don't worry the giants
will lose their fair share and jump back
into this conversation
they'll make it competitive it's a lot
more fortunately
fortunately for the giants they don't
play the jets this
year which would guarantee a second win
for the
the best team in new york now clearly
the best team in new york buffalo
because
they actually have a win buffalo well
you know what i know new york city
new jersey new jersey
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports